All types of students from all over the world
And often I'm talking about math and science
and i say something that usually surprises people
I will tell students and other people that I get goosebumps doing math
I always have. Even as a kid, I loved doing math problems
Well uh, people sometimes say to me, "Well how did that happen?"
And I tell a story. You know we all love the products of our child experiences.
Things that happened to us as kids, and I was very fortunate to have really wonderful parents.
Who enjoyed reading to me when I was a very little kid
And I started reading very early. And loved the reading.
Well, somehow my parents decided they wanted to see how to connect the reading to playing with money and with objects involving math
And before I knew it, when I was fairly fairly young, I was solving math word problems
Involving money, loving it, loving it.
Understanding that if I had 3 dimes and my dad had 2 quarters
and we'd put all of our money together, that we'd have $0.80.
And learning later on that that was the same as 80% of a dollar.
Or that it was 8 over 10
And so all of a sudden, I began to see how language and math came together
But I also began to understand how you could think about math
and anything you do.
If you look at the number of people in a room
If you look at the weight of people
If you look at the room itself, and you come to understand shapes and you see rectangles
and squares and you think about the area in a room, and the perimeter.
All these terms that you hear, in some class. In geometry, or in algebra.
And for me, what was interesting was that most students didn't like math.
And in class, as a little kid, I would watch other students either being bored or frustrated
because they weren't understanding the problem.
And so I did something that was especially helpful to me
in deciding what I wanted to do for the rest of my life.
I began to tutor kids, I began to get really excited about the idea that maybe I could help somebody else
to understand the problem. Or to grasp a concept.
Or to get excited about the work.
I wanted more people excited about math because I just thought it was fun.
And what became clear to me was that it was much harder to explain something to another student
than it was simply for me to understand it myself.
And a-ha! Then I realized here's my challenge:
I have to figure out how to use language that is so clear and simple
that I can explain a concept, because I understand the concept myself well,
that I can get someone else to not only understand whatever it is the teacher is talking about
but then to help that student learn how to solve the problem
and to develop confidence. Because what was also clear was that because I had exposure to math
at home and reading. And because I was always solving math problems, I was getting better and better.
The lesson there was that we learn to do by doing.
I found that the more I read, the better a reader I became
And the more I enjoyed reading, quite frankly, the more reading I did.
The same thing in mathematics.
When a student seems to feel less than confident about the math
it's usually because they've gotten confused about a problem or have not had success.
All of a sudden, by the time I was 13, I was in a special math program
at a university for the summer.
And the professor came into the class, this was at Tuskegee,
and it was a  National Science Foundation program for smart kids in math.
And all of a sudden, first of all, I realized I wasn't the smartest person in the world
that there were a lot of people who had done even more than I had and I was inspired by that.
But the professor came in and he put a math problem on the board
and we all looked at it and nobody could solve it.
And he said, "See me when you can solve it." And he left.
And people were really frustrated, because they were thinking,
"The teacher's supposed to help you solve the problem."
And his point was, "No, you work on it."
And I found myself less frustrated and much more fascinated.
Because what he was saying was, I had the ability if I really worked on it,
to solve that problem. Even though I didn't have a clue about how to do it.
So we spent days working on this problem and statistics
And what I learned was that even though we couldn't get the complete answer
we learned so much in struggling with the issue.
Well, the reason math is so fascinating to me, in general,
is that it teaches you to look at a problem from different perspectives.
And not necessarily to be so frustrated,
because you find yourself not able to solve it
I also found as I went through college, quite frankly,
was that math was at the foundation of all the other sciences and engineering
Whether you're going to study chemistry or physics, even when you look at something like accounting.
You know, from my point of view, the problems in those areas
are really applied math problems in engineering, or physics.
And so I realized that math became somewhat of a gatekeeper
to many other areas. And I took my interest in helping other people to do math
and my understanding of the relationship between math and other disciplines
as a sign for me to think about really focusing on teaching math
and then to focus on helping more students to become interested in math,
science, and engineering. And what happened as I got older was this,
I began to realize that many of the problems that we face in our world,
not just in our country, whether they're problems involving economics
and understanding the challenges we face with financial situations in America.
All we're looking at are the probability we'll see certain kinds of
environmental issues in different countries
or we're thinking about health disparities,
where often such areas as statistics and math will be very important.
Because the scientists and the engineers use the tools of math
in solving problems. Well I'm at a university that really enjoys
seeing students excel and about half of our students are in
math, science, and engineering.
And what is especially important to think about when you think
about producing students who will become scientists,
is that for any student, being able to do well in math in high school
and then in college, will determine in large part the ability of
that student to become a physician, an engineer, or a scientist.
But also an accountant, as I said, or an economist, or somebody in the business world.
Wherever you go, more and more, you're going to see people in mathematics
or people with math backgrounds. And if you think about people in the social sciences,
if you're interested in things involving sociology, or psychology.
Again the quantitative methods piece will be very important
because we don't solve problems and draw conclusions based on anecdotal information.
We really do need to be able to look at data, for example,
and analyze it, and use statistical measures, and look at the average,
or look at the highest frequency, or look at the probability that
something will happen. And more and more, as people become these different professions,
whether it is in the social sciences or the natural sciences or engineering,
they see the importance of mathematics.
What's been fascinating to me over the past 40 years,
is to understand that even in my work as an administrator at a college,
as president of the University of Maryland, Baltimore county here in D.C.
Math comes in handy every day, in the work that I do.
Whether it's talking about issues involving the budget, or looking at,
what we call, analytics, how you go about analyzing trends
and what's happening at the university.
And even when I think about trying to encourage people
to go into different disciplines. Let me give you an example,
we work heavily with the National Security Agency.
A lot of my students are interested in intelligence work and defense.
And NSA said to us, we need you to help us produce more mathematicians of all kinds.
Because this will be very important to have people from different perspectives,
people of all races, people of all ethnicities, who know enough math
so that they can be involved in helping to serve the country.
There's nothing more noble, I think, than serving one's country,
or saving a life, or working on the problems that can help life to be better for all of us.
And what I found is that when working with NSA and talking with students,
the first thing they'll say is, "Well, how will I use the math?"
And when students get chances to have internships and to work in places
around the country, but in the science and technology infrastructure of the country,
places like the National Institutes of Health, NASA, or the National Security Agency.
All of a sudden, they begin to see how the math and the science
they've had in their classes will relate to the real world.
And for me, explaining that foundation of math
for all these areas has always been exciting.
Now what I tend to do when I'm talking to students,
whether they are 11 or 20, is to give them a math problem.
If you're going to talk about math, why not simply give people a math problem?
Here's an example of the problem I would give, and what I always tell students is,
don't answer immediately, I want you to take the time to think about it.
The problem says this, and I remember, as I give you this math problem,
I'm getting goosebumps -- goosebumps!
29 children are in a class, 20 have dogs, 15 have cats,
how many have both -- a dog and a cat?
I actually found that problem in The Baltimore Sun,
and it was saying that many teachers and others were having problems with it.
Well, for most people, even people who like math, you'll find that
they'll want to give you an answer quickly. And the fact is,
that most of the time, that answer is not correct.
What has to happen is, from my perspective, is that the teacher
or whoever is working with you on that problem has to say, "We'll draw it!"
And the first thing people will do if they've had algebra is to give me Venn diagrams,
and I'll say, "I don't want Venn diagrams, I want you to see the children, the dogs, and the cats."
Because I want people to understand that math can be related to real life,
in a way that it helps explain the world.
And so if you can see 3 rows, 10 kids with dogs, another 10 kids with dogs,
and then put down the other 9 kids, and look at how the cats relate to that.
What you'll have to see, because I'm not going to give you the answer,
is that it takes strong thinking skills, it takes patience,
and it takes the ability to understand how one thing connects to another.
The foundation for me in math: thinking skills, reading skills,
the importance of language, having the patience to look at
the problem from different perspectives.
I can't think of any profession that's more interesting or fascinating than mathematics.
Thank you.